ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะอ่ะ
เมื่อวันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่ 29
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้า
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะ
2022 เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้
วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 28
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศต.ค.ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2
พรุ่งนี้นี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 30 เดือน
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตตปีพตต
2565 ปีคศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
222 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 น 11 โมงกี่นาทีคะ 38 นาทีค่ะ
38 นาทีเนาะก็เป็นเวลากลางวันมหาเป็นตอน
กลางวัน
อ่อนกันร้อนไหมคะผู้หญิง
ร้อนค่ะแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ย
34 องศาเซลเซียส
ร้อนไหมพระอาทิตย์เนี่ยใหญ่มาก
ไงไอ้พระอาทิตย์ใหญ่มากนะจ๊ะใช่ค่ะ
อยู่บ้านเหนียวอยู่บ้านเนี่ยไม่โอเคผู้
หญิงก็ต้องคิดไปช้อปปิ้งดีกว่าผู้หญิงจะ
ไปช้อปปิ้งหรอฟ้าไปด้วยได้มั้ยได้ค่ะ
เพราะว่าครูฟ้ากับรูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นผู้หญิง
ภูฟ้ากับครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นผู้หญิงเนี่ย
shopping  shopping  shopping มากๆครู
ฟ้า
ชอบช้อปปิ้งอะไรมากๆรู้ปลาชอบช้อปปิ้ง
อะไรมากๆหรอโน้ท
รูฟ้าชอบกระเป๋าค่ะผู้หญิง
เหมือนกันครูหญิง God
ผู้หญิงก็ชอบช็อปปิ้งกระเป๋า
กระเป๋าผู้หญิงก็ชอบช็อปปิ้งกระเป๋า
เหมือนกันผู้หญิงวิ่งไปช็อปปิ้งกระเป๋า
ที่ไหนคะกูเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์สยามพารากอน Big
C  Lotus  Shopping กระเป๋าทุกที่เลย
สายที่บ้านครูหญิงเนี่ยก็เลยมีกระเป๋า
กระเป๋ากระเป๋ากระเป๋ากระเป๋ามากๆสุภาว่า
ครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงชอบช็อปปิ้งกระเป๋าแบบไหนบ้างที่
บ้านครูหญิงมีใช่ไหมครูฟ้าครูหญิงแน่นะคะ
มีกระเป๋าเป้นี้เราเรียกว่าเขาเป้สมัย
กระเป๋าโอ้นี่เนี่ยก็จะมีสาย
สายสะพายหน้าที่เราใส่ทรายค่ะก็อย่างนี้
ใช่ไหม
ใส่ข้างหลัง
สะพายเป้เป้
หลังนะคะกระเป๋าเป้
ยูฟ้ารูฟ้ามีกระเป๋าเป้ไหม
สู้ฟ้ามีกระเป๋าเป้ค่ะครูหญิงนี่
เหมาเป้ครูฟ้าสีชมพู
ใช่กระเป๋าเป้คู่ฟ้าสีชมพูสีชมพูแล้วก็มี
สายมีสาย 2 ข้างเหมือนกันมีนี่ด้วยคู่
หญิงอันนี้อะไรอ่ะฟ้า
อันนี้หูหิ้ว
ใช่ถ้าไม่อยากสะพายสมัยไม่อยากสบายเป้เป้
ก็
มือถือได้ใช่ไหมมีใช่ค่ะถือได้ถือๆก็
คล้ายๆกันอยู่เนาะ
คล้ายๆกันเลยนะคะคล้ายๆนะไม่เหมือน of
รู้ฝามีกระเป๋าเป้กี่ไบต์ที่ภาษานี
กระเป๋าเป้
3 ใบค่ะ
3 ใบทำไมใช่เพราะอ่ะต.ค.นี้ใบที่ 1 ใช่
ไหมแล้วก็อีกใบนึงคุณแม่ซื้อให้อ่ะอา
อีก 1 ใบเนี่ยกูฟ้าซื้อ Notebook
คอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็แถมฟรีมาหนึ่งไปงอกฟ้า
ก็เลยมีกระเป๋าเป้ 3 ใบใช่ 3 พย.โห
ออกไปเฮ้ยจิตมี 2 ใบ 2 ใบครูหญิงมี
กระเป๋าเป้ 2 ใบ 2 ใบกระเป๋าเป้เนี่ยใหญ่
นะๆ
แล้วก็อีกเนี่ยมี
มีอะไรอีก
นี่ค่าเราเรียกว่ากระเป๋าสะพายข้างใช่ไหม
แบบนี้
กระเป๋าสะพายข้างกระเป๋าสะพายข้างนะคะครู
ฟ้ามีกระเป๋าสะพายข้างไหมลูกค้ามีกระเป๋า
สะพายข้างค่ะมีครูหญิงเนี่ยสะพายข้างซ้าย
นะคะสาดข้างซ้ายค่ะครูฟ้าก็สะพายข้างซ้าย
หาผู้หญิงมีเหมือนกันอันนี้แขนซ้ายไม้ไฟ
ฟ้าขอให้กระเป๋าข้างซ้ายค่ะผู้หญิงจ่าย
ค่ะเหมือนกันเนาะคุยคะมีกระเป๋าสะพายข้าง
กี่ใบ
ลูกค้ามีกระเป๋าสะพายข้าง
2 ใบขอ 2 ใบ
2 ใบค่ะใช้คุณ 2 ใบผู้หญิงมีกระเป๋า
สะพายข้างกี่ใบคะครูหญิงมีกระเป๋าสะพาย
ข้าง
สี่ใบ Note  4 ใบมีใบนี้เนี่ยเล็กๆสมัย
เล็กๆแต่ว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะมี
มีกระเป๋าสะพายข้างเหมือนกันแต่ใบนี้
เนี่ยใหญ่ไหมอันนี้เล็กลึกใหญ่นะคะนี้
แหละกระเป๋ามีสายสีเหลืองมากเลยคะ
แล้วก็สะพายข้างเฮ้ยเบี้ยอ้าผู้หญิงสี
เหลืองและฟ้าชอบสีเหลือง
ไม่ดีค่ะคุณความรู้สิคะเลอะหมดแล้ว
เลอะหมดแล้วหรอสะพายข้างใบใหญ่แต่ถ้าไม่
อยากสะพายก็มีหูหิ้ว
ได้ถ้าไม่ถ้ากูหญิงไม่สะพายข้างก็จะเป็น
กระเป๋าถือนะครับมือถือเธอ
คิดนี่อันนี้ถือกระเป๋าใบนี้หรือไม่ได้
มึงได้เอาดีมากเลยครับผู้หญิง
โอเคผู้หญิงก็มีอีกนะ
ผู้หญิงมีกระเป๋าอะไรอีกคะ
ครูหญิงมีกระเป๋าปะนี่ก็บอกแล้วกระเป๋า
คาดอกนิ
อ่าใส่แบบนี้นะฮะกระเป๋าคาดอกครูฟ้ามีตระ
เป๋าคาดออกไหม
ไม่มีค่ะคุณฟ้าไม่มีกระเป๋าคาดอกเมื่อ
ก่อนมีหนึ่งแต่ว่า
ไม่รู้อยู่ไหนเออตอนนี้ไม่มีครูฟ้าไม่มี
กระเป๋าคาดอกผู้หญิงมีกระเป๋าคาดอกกี่ใบ
ใหม่เดียว
ไม่ไปเกี่ยวแม่กระเป๋าที่กรูหญิงมีมากที่
สุดในบ้านนะคะในบ้านครูอีกแหละกระเป๋าที่
ครูหญิงมีมากที่สุดก็คือ
กระเป๋าผ้าค่ะกระเป๋าผ้า
กระเป๋าผ้าใช่ไหมหรือว่าเราเรียกเป๋า
สะพายบาตรได้มั้ยกระเป๋าสะพายข้างเยอะมี
กระเป๋าทั้ง
นี่ค่ะนักเรียนไหนกด e คือกระเป๋าผ้าของ
ครูหญิงคุยเยอะมากเยอะมากเลย 1  2
3  4
5  6
7  8
โห
rs-12
ประมาณ 11  12 ใบนะครับระเป๋าค่าครูหญิง
เนี่ยไผกระเป๋าผ้ากระเป๋าผ้าเนี่ยมันมัน
ใหญ่ใช่ไหมๆไม่มีซิปนะคะอย่ากระน.ศ.ไทย
เนี่ยมีซิปหน่อยสิ
กระเป๋าผ้าเนี่ยไม่มีซิปเวลาเปิดแล้วก็
หยิบของง่ายๆครูฟ้าหนูฟ้ามีกระเป๋าผ้าไหม
คะลูกค้ามีกระเป๋าผ้าค่ะผู้หญิงกระเป๋า
ผ้านะคะ
เดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะ
กระเป๋าผ้าในก็จะมีอะไรอ่ะมีอะไรคะ
กระเป๋าผ้าอีเห็นไหมอันนี้เป็น
ฝายหือหนูกระเป๋านะกระเป๋าแล้วก็เป็น
กระเป๋าผ้าสายฟ้ามีกระเป๋าผ้าเยอะไหมคะ
ลูกฟ้ามีกระเป๋าผ้า
มีกระเป๋าผ้าประมาณ 3 ใบ
3 ใบนะคะไม่เยอะค่ะไม่สั่งซื้อ
น้อยกว่าครูหญิงผู้หญิงดีกระเป๋าภาพมากๆ
นะคะให้ดีค่ะผู้หญิงมีกระเป๋าอะไรอีกไหม
ผู้หญิงมีกระเป๋าคอมพิวเตอร์
กระเป๋าเค้าเนาะให้
กระเป๋าคอมพิวเตอร์ใช่ไหมเวลาเปิดมาข้าง
ในนะข้างในเนี่ยเราก็คอมพิวเตอร์ใส่ลงไป
แล้วเรียกกระเป๋าคอมพิวเตอร์
นะมีกระเป๋าคอมพิวเตอร์ไหมคะลูกค้ามี
กระเป๋าแบบนี้หาของบิวเต้ย
นะว่าคอมพิวเตอร์แบบเล็กๆใช่ไหม Notebook
เล็กๆหรือว่าใส่ iPad
กระเป๋าคอมพิวเตอร์ iPad ค่ะอาย
ว่า
เล็กนะเล็ก Notebook เล็กๆๆก็มีอะไรเรา
ไม่มีไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคู่ฟ้าอะไรคะคุณหญิง
กระเป๋าเงิน
กระเป๋าเงินหรือกระเป๋าตังค์กระเป๋าตังค์
ใช่มั้ยข้างในเนี่ยก็มีเงินนะคะเงินเงิน
ครูฟ้าปีกระเป๋าเงินไหมคะรูปฟ้ามีกระเป๋า
เงินค่ะผู้หญิงของครูฟ้าสื่อแบบนี้นะ
กระเป๋าเงินหรือว่ากระเป๋าตังค์ว่าชอบใช้
กระเป๋าตังค์แบบใส่มากจ่ายหรือว่าหลัง
ถ้ามีกระเป๋าเงินบางคนก็จะมีกระเป๋าใส่
เหรียญใช่ไหมคะเขาก็จะเป็นเงินนะคะเป็น
เงินที่เป็นเปลี่ยนน้องเป็นเหรียญแบบนี้
นิเมนี่แบงค์นะคะ
อันนี้เป็นเหรียญเนาะกันดูสิเหรียญหนูฟ้า
มีกระเป๋าใส่เหรียญไหมคะลูกค้ามีกระเป๋า
ใส่เหรียญค่ะข้างในก็จะเป็นเหรียญเห็นไหม
เหรียญใส่เรียนคลุยเนี่ยเป็นสี่เหลี่ยม
เป็นสีเหลี่ยม 1 กระเป๋าใส่เหรียญครูฟ้า
เนี่ยไม่ใช่สี่เหลี่ยมเนาะไม่ใช่สี่
เหลี่ยมค่ะเป็นวงกลมเป็นวงกลมกระเป๋าใส่
เหรียญครูฟ้าเป็นวงกลมนาวงกลมไงวงกลมๆก็
เป็นกระเป๋าเงิน
กระเป๋าเงินหรือว่ากระเป๋าใส่เหรียญมาคะ
อ่ะมีกระเป๋าอะไรอีกคะผู้หญิงลุย indie
กระเป๋าเวลาที่ครูหญิงไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
นะคะไปซื้อของเนาะซื้อของที่
ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตหาคุณและก็จะมีกระเป๋าหรือ
ว่าถุงเป็นกระเป๋าก็ได้เป็นถุงก็ได้นะคะ
ถุงช้อปปิ้งถุงช้อปปิ้งอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
วิลล่ามาร์เก็ตนะคะเป็นถุงช็อปปิ้งหรือ
ว่ากระเป๋าชอปปิ้งหามีไหม
มีค่ะครูหญิงเมีย
กระเป๋าชอปปิ้งหรือว่าถุงช้อปปิ้ง 1 ไหน
เวลาไปซื้อหมูซื้อไก่หนูก็จะใส่ในกระเป๋า
ชอปปิ้งมหาไหนค่ะหน้านักผู้หญิงมีกระเป๋า
ชอปปิ้งกี่ใบคะ
กระเป๋าชอปปิ้งครูหญิงมี
มากกว่า 10 ใบ
ไม่กว่า 10 ไปเลยหรอเยอะจัดครูฝาละมี
กระเป๋าชอปปิ้งกี่ใบอีก
หนึ่งก็ดีแล้วนะคะผู้หญิงมีเยอะๆทำไมไม่
เข้าใจมีเยอะทำไมอ่ะก็กูก็มีกระเป๋าช้อป
ปิ้ง 1 ใบนะคะสงสัยผู้หญิงมีกระเป๋าอัน
นี้ด้วยค่ะครูฟ้า
กระเป๋าอะไรคะครูหญิงเราเรียกว่ากระเป๋า
เก็บความเย็น
จริงหรอชายๆกับเวลาเปิดข้างในข้างในมันจะ
มีพลอยฟอยล์หรออะไรฟอยล์โดยพลอยนะคะเวลา
ที่เรามีของเย็นๆแบบนี้กาแฟเย็นแล้วหนู
ใส่ในใจเขาก็จะเย็นนานๆเนาะเราเรียกว่า
กระเป๋าเก็บความเย็นเขาเก็บความเย็น
ร้อนใช่ไหมนี่นะได้จิตนะคะครู
เนื้อหามีกระเป๋าเก็บความเย็นไหมครูปลา
ไม่มีกระเป๋าเก็บความเย็นค่ะผู้หญิงไม่มี
บางครั้งประเทศนักเรียนและร้อนนักเรียนมี
ซุปอยากให้ซุปร้อนนานๆก็จะเป็นกระเป๋า
เก็บความร้อนนะคะแล้วแต่
อันนี้ไม่มี
สถานีกระเป๋าอะไรอีกไหมอันนี้ค่ะอ่ะ
เอากระเป๋าอะไรคะเป็นกระเป๋าใส่
ของผู้ฟ้าเนี่ยคือบางคนบอกเป็นกระเป๋า
เครื่องสำอางอ๋อใส่ลิป 4 กใส่น้ำไม่ว่า
อิติกอาม้าสคาร่าอายแชโดวบัญชรอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยกระเป๋าเครื่องสำอางมือผู้หญิงมี
กระเป๋าเครื่องสำอางไหมคะมีค่ะนี่หรออัน
นี้คือกระเป๋ามือสองผู้หญิงคะข้างในก็จะ
มีเครื่องสำอางมีกระเป๋าเครื่องสำอางครู
ฟ้า
ผู้หญิงแล้วก็อะไรกระเป๋าแว่นตากระเป๋า
ใส่แว่นมั้ยเรียกกระเป๋าใส่แว่น
แว่นเวลาเปิดเนี่ยอันนี้คือแว่นอันนี้ก็
เป็นกระเป๋าใช่ไหมเป็นกระเป๋าใส่แว่นคุณ
ครูบาสจะเป็นอันนี้คือกระเป๋านะแบบนี้
แหละเป็นกระเป๋าใช่ไหมคะใช่ๆมีกระเป๋าใส่
แว่นไหมไม่มีค่ะครูมาไม่มีกระเป๋าใส่แว่น
เออไม่มีเลย
นั่นแหละก็สุดหมดแล้วมั้ยชายหมดหรือยังขอ
เดินออกไปได้ไหมคะผู้หญิงมาได้ค่ะผู้หญิง
มีกระเป๋าอีกนะคะนักเรียนแต่กระเป๋าอะไร
อันนี้เราอาจจะไม่ได้เรียกว่าเป็นกระเป๋า
ไหมอ้าวเราเรียกว่าอะไร
ใช่ไหมคะถุงอ่าเหมือนผู้หญิงขับพบฟ้ามี
ถุงช้อปปิ้ง
ไว้แต่ถ้าเราไม่มีถุงช้อปปิ้งเราไปซื้อ
ของเราก็จะได้ถุงกลับมาที่แบบเป็นหลัก
ง่ายๆกระดาษเอพีมีป้ายยี่ห้อหมดใช้
กระดาษถาดอาจจะมีของที่เราไปซื้อมาหมื่น
ถูกกระดาษเนาะแต่ถ้าไม่ใช่ถุงกระดาษก็จะ
เป็น
ถุง
คนไทยเนี่ยเรียดถุงพลาสติกของคนไทยเรียก
ถุงพลาสติกว่าอะไรอีกความรู้หูผมก็แคป
ถุงก๊อปแก๊ปนะฮะเพราะว่าเวลาฟังเนี่ยจะ
ได้ยินเสียงกรอบแกรบกรอบแกะสอบ GAT เวลา
บี้สอบ GAT แต่นักเรียนไม่ได้ยินนะครับ
เพราะว่าของผู้หญิงและซูมันตัดใคร
บางครั้งนักเรียนอาจจะได้ยินคนไทยเรียก
ถุงพลาสติกถุงก๊อบแก๊บนะคะก็เป็นถุง
เหมือนกันหรือว่าเป็นนี่กระเป๋าเนี่ย
มันจะมีเสียง
ได้ยินไหมได้ยินได้ยิน
ทรายนั่นแหละค่ะแอปมั้ยแก๊สนะคะนั่นแหละ
อันนี้ก็ได้นะอันนี้เนี่ยเราก็เรียกว่า
ถุงซักผ้า
เสื้อผ้าใช่ไหมหาแล้วใส่แล้วเหม็นก็เอา
ใส่ถุงอันนี้แล้วก็เอาไปซักนะเราก็เรียก
ถุงซักผ้าใช่ไหมสูงซักผ้าจะมีซิปนาขามอัน
นี้ก็เป็นถุงหรือว่ากระเป๋าของคนไทยแล้ว
ก็ของครูหญิงกับครูฟ้านะคะวีดีโอนี้นะคะ
ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็ไปก่อนนะคะไปส่งเงิน
หน้าสวัสดีค่ะกินข้าว